o la declaratoria de invalidez de esta
primera parte del paquete de reformas
electorales que como bien señalas tienen
que ver con comunicación social y con
responsabilidades administrativas Qué
significa que no no podrá operar no
podrá ponerse en marcha esta parte de
las reformas con los argumentos de que
fueron viciadas de origen hubo
irregularidades en el proceso que
provocaron una transgresión del de la
deliberación democrática así lo fijó el
ministro oponente Alberto Pérez Dayan Y
tuvo el apoyo de ocho de sus compañeros
para un total de nueve votos contra dos
argumentan que la oposición no tuvo
tiempo de conocer y de analizar estas
reformas que sufrieron además
modificaciones de último momento dado
que se dispensaron todos los trámites y
se procedió a la votación sin que
insisto se discutiera a profundidad
Bueno y qué caminos le quedan a López
Obrador para aprobar estas reformas para
probarlas a tiempo además
las reformas digamos ya están aprobadas
por el congreso y ahora están siendo
impugnadas en la corte queda todavía el
segundo paquete la segunda parte que
tiene que ver con el adelgazamiento del
INE del Instituto Nacional electoral el
presidente López Obrador ha anticipado
que si la corte hecha abajo Todo el
paquete de reformas del llamado Plan B
él ya tiene un plan C Que consiste en
Llamar a votar todos a favor de de su
partido de su movimiento y ni un solo
voto a lo que él considera son
conservadores ese ha dicho es su plan c
en caso de que la corte tumbe todo este
conjunto de normas Pero además a la par
de este Plan B también sean reformado se
han sustituido los consejeros de este
instituto nacional electoral y ahora la
nueva presidenta de acuerdo con la
oposición pues es afín al
régimen al gobierno de López Obrador por
lo que también es una vía para llevar a
cabo los cambios que él está planteando
a pesar de este revés de la corte